Mitchell Billings the Castle's Medical
Professional specializing in PTSD and
complex PTSD has provided extensive
assistance to soldiers returning from
conflict zones aiding them in addressing
their trauma lactus Chasm at DCd
headquarters agent get him back to us
[Music]
born and raised in Virginia Dr Mitchell
Billings grew up as the son of a career
military man he watched over the years
her deployments would transform his
father
the events his father had witnessed
during his deployment had taken a toll
on his psyche and when he returned home
to his family he was a Broken Man
hostile and reactive
he experienced hypervigilance and
paranoia causing him to constantly lock
every door and continually look over his
shoulder for perceived threats
he often suffered from nightmares and
flashbacks that would cause him to
relive past traumatic events again and
again as if they were happening for the
first time
being back home with his family he left
an outlet for his anger which meant he
regularly engaged and displaced
aggression towards them
recognizing his immense struggles and
the pain he was going through his wife
took it upon herself to try and help her
husband
he had always loved to use his hands and
took great pride in tending to things
outside of their home
with this in mind she encouraged him to
try building birdhouses on their porch
outside
being in nature made him feel bitter
along with a sense of purpose and
satisfaction with completing a birdhouse
for the garden's woodpeckers or sparrows
gardening combined repetition with a
creative outcome which was soothing for
him helping to relieve stress and
anxiety
he could lose himself in gentle
movements when gardening and Achieve
mindfulness
he found that growing things from seeds
or saplings or simply keeping his Lawns
looking healthy brought him a wonderful
sense of satisfaction
witnessing his mother's ability to
handle his father's rage and PTSD
through acts of service patience and
concentration Mitchell recognized her
effective coping strategies for stress
relief
inspired by her emotional intelligence
and determined to mend wounded Souls it
pursued Psychiatry as his field of study
specializing in treating soldiers
returning from conflict zones
developing expertise in PTSD and complex
PTSD Mitchell completed his residency at
Walter Reed General Hospital before the
outbreak of the green poison
when the true Sun sees control of Walter
Reed he saw an opportunity to continue
his work by healing soldiers in need
with his guidance many of the true Sons
recognized that their decisions had
stemmed from Pain and Trauma they came
to understand that breaking the cycle
was possible enabling them to make
healthier choices for themselves and
their community
later on Billings would be rescued by
the division where he was being held by
the true Sons at a Detention Center
once freed he'll continue with his
mission of healing and Rehabilitation of
those in need
after his rescue at Manny's request Dr
Mitchell Billings would begin sessions
with members of the team in DC
weird we're good
and take time to adjust and find your
role in this community
oh I've already got a job and I'm not
alone I've got Fred
that's good is your boyfriend
oh God no Fred
we're just friends
he couldn't handle this
besides I'm pretty sure he's still
broken after the [__] his ex put him
through
well I'm glad to see you haven't lost
your sense of humor if you're not
laughing you're crying and if you're
crying you're dying
you've been through a lot haven't you
you wouldn't believe it
no one ever believes the truth
you know
I find sometimes people surprise you if
you let them
that's hard doc
to let people in
if you never let them in they can never
disappoint you
well you know sometimes people use their
strength and humor as a shield
or a weapon
exactly
this is a safe place you don't have to
protect yourself anymore
you can put down the armor then
you're good dog
why did you join the true Sons
[__] I guess we're diving deep today
it seemed like a good idea at the time
even with what happened to Roosevelt
Island
I didn't know [__] all about that
my job was keeping the lights on you
focus on the job you can lose sight of a
lot of [__] up [__]
do you think Ridgeway kept you in the
dark on purpose
I think everyone does that
there's no way for anyone to know
everything so people only tell you what
you need to know to get the job done
that's leadership and chain of command
you follow orders and Trust they are for
a reason
and you decided to stop following orders
what changed we did
Ridgeway wanted to cut our losses
we all know about acceptable loss
we know about collateral damage but
Anderson he was chasing Danger
he was courting loss he wasn't trying to
stop the hemorrhaging
with Ridgeway we were doing what we had
to to save the most people
with Anderson
he just wanted power
how else do you explain him partnering
with Sokolova
did anyone else hear a little round of
feelings towards Lewis this wasn't
pointed out but it certainly fills my
need for some scandalous Revelations
however regardless Mitchell would
eventually break through Wally's walls
and find out how she is really feeling
it's not that she didn't know about a
lot of the horrible stuff that the true
Sons were doing it's more that she chose
to focus on the work she'd been given
and ignore what was potentially
happening around her
because with Ridgeway they actually felt
like they were helping and saving people
but after Anderson took over everything
changed it didn't seem like he cared
about what was happening to the true
Sons just that he was trying to gain
power
how are you feeling today Fred
honestly yes
weird
like I don't know how the hell I got
here
what do you mean
it doesn't seem fair that I'm alive that
Manny sent the agents to bring me back
and most of my men are dead
on this circumstance survivor's guilt is
understandable
I know but it's more than that I just
I don't know how I got this lucky I
don't know why Manny would do that for
me
your brothers in arms you've been
through a lot together
yeah but I followed Ridgeway I could
have been a spy for Sokolova
are you a spy
[__] no
why do you think Manny would put his
people at risk to bring you in
because he wanted to squeeze me for
Intel
that's why he sent me to you dog
do you feel like this is an
interrogation
not really no
why do you think Manny sent you to me to
talk
make sure I'm okay
why would he do that
because he's worried I'm not okay
why would he rescue you
because he cares about me
why would he bring you in
because he trusts me
how do you feel now
like I want my life
and how are you gonna pay back that debt
I have no idea
you know it's not something you can ever
pay back right
yeah
nonetheless [__] really gets [__] up
thanks Doc
don't do anything rash
Lewis still feels extremely guilty for
what he's done and even more so because
many would risk the life of others to
rescue him yet most of the men under his
command were killed
many genuinely cares for Lewis but this
only makes him feel more guilty
Lewis knows that he owes many everything
and will do everything in his power to
pay back that debt
however as we know by now Lewis wouldn't
have much time left after this
conversation as he would meet us in
protecting the White House following
Natalya's attack on the compound
how are you feeling today Alani cow
sound how are you feeling today agent
Kelso
do we really have to do this
we don't have to do anything
don't therapize me
if you don't find these sessions helpful
we don't need to continue
I just don't know what I'm doing here in
these sessions or in DC
DC
you miss your team in New York
I miss my family in New York
interesting ah don't do that [__]
do you feel like this isn't your family
anymore
I don't know these people
do you feel like Manny is replacing you
I feel like he doesn't need me this
isn't my home anymore
how do you feel in New York
like they want me there
they don't just need me
they actually want me to be there
you don't think people want you to be
here
I think the longer I stay and the more
things change the less anyone would care
if I left
it's not like there's much love for the
division around here
frankly it feels like you think I'm a
traitor
and I swear to God if I if I hear one
more person talk [__] about fate
you know I used to be CIA making a
murderer look like an accident is like
spycraft 101.
well we now know what Kelso has been
hiding out during the season she's been
taking some time out with her family in
New York but also that she no longer
feels like she has a place in DC but she
isn't needed anymore
she also said that she suspects that
people see her as a traitor now not to
break the immersion here but I fully
feel like this could be a jab back at me
for all the perhaps misplaced videos
about Kelso being a traitor or Rogue if
we go back a year or so when this was
likely being written I was in full swing
with my what the hell is Kelso doing
videos where I was accusing her of doing
all sorts of things against the division
probably just over analyzing but I'm
totally taking some responsibility for
this in all fairness I really like
Kelso's character she just terrifies me
and she's a little bit crazy however
I'll admit I like a little bit of crazy
how are you doing
anything I should be worried about I'm
not going to tell you what to talk about
with my other patients no of course not
I didn't mean you know you don't have to
take care of everyone
you don't have to control everything
of course not
it's okay to let go and enjoy yourself
Manny
I do enjoy myself
I know
how are things with Maori
good
I like her she's smart she challenges me
to get out of my head
funny
distracts me as a very cerebral person
no she is but she uh
fully commits to anything she does
so when we're together we're very
together if
do I really have to talk about this
no you don't but you should talk to Mari
about the baby
yeah
I want it she wants it we want it but
yeah we don't know if it's smart or good
timing
oh there is never a good timing
well there's bad timing and there's
giving birth in a war zone
babies are born in war zones all the
time
I don't know how to do this job and be a
dad what do you mean I have to stay calm
and measured and make tough choices
I don't want my kid to think I'm some
cold heartless [__] workaholic
my father's come in all shapes and sizes
I guess but if I'm gonna have a kid I
want to be with that kid
you know you could learn a few things
from Wally and Fred about parenting they
don't have any kids
no
they know that sometimes the best way to
decompress and manage stress is to
accept that there is no way to solve the
problem
if you can laugh at your situation
you won't be consumed by it
this particular session just confirms
exactly what we know about many as well
as the way he's been feeling of this
last season
he has an intense need to be of control
in every situation and is a deep-seated
fear about not being good enough to
Father his unborn child
he takes on an immense amount of
responsibility and deems himself as the
sole person responsible for the outcome
and everything that has happened in DC
he needs to find a way to decompress to
learn to share the load with other
trusted individuals around him recognize
the good he has done and learn to let go
of the guilty feels or it will
eventually consume him
is this the start of a downward spiral
for many do we need to talk to Kelso and
get her back to DC
intelligence had recently surfaced
revealing that Mitchell Billings was
being held somewhere in the Constitution
Hall District of Washington DC further
inspection revealed that he's been held
at the haunted house control point
arriving at The Outpost agents were
greeted by an enormous unit of true Sons
but the agents were prepared for this
with their overwhelming training and
Firepower including the super magical
Slayer snowball Cannon they were able to
make short work of them and upon their
elimination many would be heard of the
comms
Work Camp
a therapist
Soca love is using him to treat people
maybe I've been wrong about her
[Music]
ignoring many's doubts the agents waste
no time and head off towards the outcast
Work Camp
arriving at the location that was marked
on the map the agents clear a small
group of true sons that were mulling
about on the street then without warning
they were ambushed by a much larger
group coming from a balcony above
fortunately for them the agents were
wearing their Logitech G Pro X wireless
headsets with 50mm drivers and pro-grade
Precision Audio so they heard them
coming from a mile away hashtag
sponsored once the hostels were cleared
out they made their way deeper into the
camp and came across the high value
Target and after eliminating him they
were able to intercept a hostile comms
burnout
they need a break they can't maintain
the space same floor for the assessment
Dr Billy I'll send a relief team as soon
as possible
get to the nest
Mitchell is advising Natalya on the
state of omen but also gives the agents
the last location he'd been spotted
[Music]
throwing all caution into the wind the
agents charge into the site with
absolutely no planning and would quickly
pay the price
agent killed
after recomposing themselves they would
rush back in this time with backup
despite the challenging weather it
wasn't long before this site 2 was
cleared and brought under friendly
control
but unfortunately they would discover
that Mitchell has long gone from the
area
putting him on a radio what the hell is
he doing
the agents replenish their suppliers and
head off to the true Sons broadcast
Outpost
traveling to the southeasternmost part
of the district the agents would come
across a lightly defended building
making their way to the roof they
surprised another group of true sons who
seem completely unaware of the murder of
their friends just moments ago on the
street below
entering the building it wasn't long
before the leader on site made his
presence known
but once again he alongside his troops
were merely a hindrance and were quickly
dispatched headquarters
we gotta move
[Music]
burying on the side of caution the
agents scope out the entrance of the DCd
headquarters before pushing ahead mainly
because their usual Run and Gun approach
proved unsuccessful a couple of times in
a row Dr Billings has helped all of us
heal and work together
be careful agent I don't like that
sokolov has brought him here
agent requesting backup
moving through the compound it was
starting to get pretty clear to the
agents that these true Sons had a lot
harder than the previous ones building
up to this Mission and that maybe they
could have equipped a more flexible
build however regardless they pushed on
thank you
not only were they fighting more
ferociously but they were in much larger
numbers Mitchell was obviously very
close by
hostile radio intercepted
decisions
please take a chance to breathe
and recalibrate yourself
not just your weapon thanks dog
I don't understand what she's trying to
do
they continue to push through the
facility attempting to waste as little
time as possible to catch up with
Mitchell before he's once again moved on
eventually they would be confronted by
the true Sun's leader Lieutenant young
and after taking out his guards they
turned their attention to him and while
using potentially the most painful and
impractical weapon in the game they
would slowly take him down
that goes on me
got you agent
God
a dog Billings I'll see you back at the
castle agent please come see me if you
ever want to talk
when Mitchell had been safely returned
to the castle settlement Manny would
catch up with him for a debrief
yeah
just to do my job
whenever soldiers are approached from
burnout
she wanted me to do psych evals on them
did you not at all
but a few before your agent rescued me
she didn't hurt you or force you to do
my job no she didn't force me
she asked me to talk to some troubled
soldiers and I talk to them
I took a nose
it doesn't matter that I was a prisoner
I'm a doctor first
you don't choose your patience you don't
choose who gets help you help the people
who need it regardless of their
loyalties
is there anything you can tell me
I can't give you any specifics on my
patients
what about patterns
what do they say about Sokolova any
patterns of abuse manipulation control
no Manny
I'm glad the opposite the only reason
her soldiers are still here is because
of her leadership
they feel respected listened to and
cared for
even in death she finds a way to honor
them
they adore her
mature was asked to help her by
performing psych evaluations on Black
Tusk soldiers
after all these months some of them were
starting to show signs of burnout and
depression
Mitchell says he was treated well and
that this is his job and he was happy to
assist her with the request
his mission is and has always been to
help those in need regardless of what
side they're on
many digs deeper tried to find out
anything that Natalia is doing in the
background but Mitchell says it's
actually much different to how many
imagines her control of the black task
would be
his soldiers respect her and feel valued
she is the only reason they're still
doing what they do given the situation
the world is in right now
it's pretty obvious that many is really
starting to struggle with how all of
these prisoners have been treated I mean
he's glad I'm sure especially since he
still hasn't been able to recover Mari
but this is all really starting to
confuse him based on what he is hearing
from these debriefs Natalia is nothing
like he imagined should be
I've been calling this out since the
very first rescue Natalia is playing a
new game one that paints her in the
black task in a different light
but in reality I don't think anything
has changed she still needs to be
stopped she's just attacking the
remaining jtf and division agents in a
different way
she's casting doubt and on top of this
she's attempting to turn civilians over
to their side
sadly I think many is a little bit
vulnerable right now and with Murray
gone in the pregnancy he isn't in the
right State of Mind to make proper
judgments
hi all I know I'm incredibly late to the
party with this one real life has been
keeping me pretty busy so it took me a
long time to even play through this
Target but I think I'm all good now and
the video should start coming out as per
usual
I also know this isn't quite the video
that people were waiting for given the
conclusion comes out to these manhunts
at the same time as the last minor
Target there are a lot of questions that
come out at the same time however I have
a system and I'm too OCD to break it but
don't worry I'm already part way through
the next video and it should hopefully
be out soon I'll admit though I'm going
to be a little bit unhinged and off
script in that one because the
speculations start flying anyways thank
you very much for all the messages
asking if I'm okay I am I'm just crazy
busy otherwise thank you very much for
watching this video and I'll catch you
soon in the next one extremist malice
extreme remedia
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]